yeah I remember I went to Africa one
time as I got a little bit older and I
was like holy [ __ ] you know a lot of
Africans are black you know yeah yeah
and I was like and that's when I
realized like heaven is mostly gonna be
like black and Asian people you know
it's not gonna be that many white people
there a lot of Indians Chinese and black
yeah yeah
China has like 1 billion India has 1
billion and they're dying
are they no I'm pretty quick I mean it's
gonna be packed up there when you think
about why you think about this to think
about this I thought about this is that
you know how you know when like white
people they're pets yeah they do
funerals they go who will see you in
heaven oh yeah you think that all the
cats that are left and dogs there's ever
lived on planet Earth I'm gonna be in
heaven too because if it is I don't want
to be there bro all the bees ever
existed oh the allergies yeah I'd have
to open up a pharmacy up there for
people you can't so you can open a
pharmacy
dude you're gonna ruin it yeah you can't
be this crazy guy who's bringing wood
and [ __ ] up people believe people who
believe in heaven believe only humans
get to go to heaven or do they believe
all living things go to heaven that's a
good question my belief and I'm not sure
exactly where how much of religion was
in or just this idea that I had was that
it was me and probably other people that
I picked to be there and like my loved
ones you know for some reason in my head
realizing everybody's there ok so how
does this work if you've died I think
you feels right yeah but you what if
those loved ones don't don't go to
heaven if they don't go to heaven then
you just get like a memo or something or
you hear what like a verbal memo yeah
you know is it heaven for you then if
you can't be with that loved one who
didn't make it to heaven then you that's
just the way it kind of shakes out
happens about 85% of what you want right
I don't think a hundred percent anymore
yeah there's so many pews to be a
hundred I think there was a time and
it's probably on a percent you know
everybody just made it up there
everybody in the Internet age right in
that market yeah and it's also how
Christians say they say no matter what
you've done on planet Earth how evil you
are if you accept Jesus Christ as your
Lord and Savior yeah that you will go to
heaven yeah so with that in mind you'll
you'll be up there with some people that
you know don't necessarily want to be
around right some killers who took him
in at the last minute right right like
you know imagine being eaten by Jeffrey
Dahmer yeah he's right right his fridge
up there it is fridge make and then he
before he died in prison he accepted
Jesus yeah and so now you're chilling on
a cloud with Cleopatra and the ones you
want to hang out with
yeah you know we you know got Dirty Jobs
yeah that guy yeah yeah yeah and then
all of a sudden Micro gamma floats by on
a cloud I mean how do you feel
hmm who are the people you want to see
most in heaven top five
and his side of my family or in history
in history like Lou Reed is one of yours
well no I went to Lou Reed from the
Baltimore Ravens yeah Velvet Underground
I've heard of them yeah yeah yeah I'm
trying to think I would probably go
Columbus probably why he seems boring
Christopher Columbus you know a [ __ ] you
you know anything about his personality
is aggression but bro that's gonna be
right
oh we know about this one right is that
like I get on the boat I think let's go
west Yeah right that's so but you don't
know what he's gonna be like in eternity
you don't know his little [ __ ] quirks
and whatnot
no you don't know what he's gonna be
like I'll know what he's gonna be like
cuz he's in my [ __ ] top five Bobby
all right and I like that
yeah because here's the thing do to get
onto a boat that's the bravest thing and
just go somewhere you're not even
knowing for sure if like the world is
round or flat at that time well they did
already know and every morning you get
up and you have to like kind of make
sure one of your buddies doesn't have a
disease for you like get real close to
him like that's crazy bro curvy kill you
dude
yeah I cold will kill you you couldn't
make why not Magellan then bro Oh
Magellan would have been better but he
did kill a lot of people too and he can
lot of yeah I like Columbus number two
Columbus number two maybe probably one
of the kids from that movie have you
seen the movie with Johnny Depp where he
plays Peter Pan
yeah Finding Neverland yeah yeah one of
the kids from that probably which kids
the main kid with the freckles like kind
of an estimate their most troubled one
who else Christian Bale probably need
straight-up cooter on this Alvin is what
do we get probably ooh one of the chicks
from Friday Night Lights yeah Ali Landry
mm tall blond what is the one I want the
one with the whipped cream
I don't even know I'm talking about the
right movie so you we need a mother
figure we need somebody to help take
care of everyone Judi Dench names she's
not dead yet Jesus she'll be done when
he's dead she doesn't seem like she has
any mother they'll get her breast
somebody can help out yeah somebody with
some yeah Kathy big Anna Nicole yeah
your old mill knows okay I don't know
whose movie the good yogurt now it's a
still fertile and Anna Nicole Smith yeah
she seems just like she just be such a
pain in the ass yo Boatwright it's gonna
be about her I feel like you know I
don't good mother I don't know Mom let
me say something right now doing I ain't
gonna visit you and have it I'll tell
you that right now
really [ __ ] your [ __ ] people bro
who's your people dude I have people too
bro okay all right this is an
opportunity for you to tell them though
all right I'll tell you my people do it
forget Lou Reed babe okay Wow you know
what I'm gonna go for it uh and he's
gonna have to choose a woman
unfortunately and this doesn't
well yeah here's yeah here's the thing
though dude it's like in your thing
right you don't have so those are the
five celebrities or whatnot right you're
gonna have your mom and your dad is
everyone else so you get to pick five
people aside from your family yeah that
you're just an overall weighs wanted to
meet in history right but first is
Gilbert can he be on the list he doesn't
have to be on my list cuz I'm already
gonna see him because my friend yeah so
five random people that don't know
you're either like alright let me do
mine alright whoa
let's all use it I think I'm the racist
slurs it I think I would do Pol Pot why
I'll tell you why because Pol Pot dude
he is the scare man yeah yeah he's the
heavy hand he's not gonna be in heads
the Rottweiler why would you think Pol
Pot would be in heaven he's no except
you don't know this when he was in the
village in Thailand right everybody
accepted Jesus Christ as Lord and Savior
and he died in Thailand did he really
did he yeah yeah he's a rock well I'll
tell you right now Thailand harbored him
oh that's right you got to live in a
[ __ ] village after he killed two
million
[Music]